[Music]
on this saturday night cop 26 criticism
[Music]
environmentalists give the climate
summit a fail canada's a laggard when it
comes to climate change chaos at a rap
concert featuring a canadian it was just
like a suffocating feeling the rush for
the stage turns deadly and the run to
remember 100 kilometers aim is honestly
nothing it pales in comparison to the
sacrifices they've made the canadian
hitting the pavement to honor veterans
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Music]
[Applause]
hundreds of people gathered in downtown
montreal today to call on the federal
government to do more to address the
climate crisis similar demonstrations
were held across canada and around the
world as part of the global day of
action for climate justice
good evening and thank you for joining
us the largest protest was in glasgow
scotland where world leaders are meeting
for cop 26. mike trolley breaks down the
demonstrator's demands and where canada
stands
there was a carnival type feeling in the
air in glasgow scotland
but the music barely masked the lack of
joy in the crowd
halfway through the two-week u.n climate
conference environmentalists had hoped
for more
a two-week long celebration of business
as usual and blah blah blah
but the facts do not lie and we know
that our emperors are naked world
leaders had set out to get enough
commitment to slow the rise in global
temperatures which have only gotten
warmer since the paris climate
conference in 2015.
protesters around the world weren't shy
in expressing their disdain for world
leaders with some of the largest
gatherings in europe
and most dramatic in australia
at the protest in glasgow dale marshall
of environmental defense says prime
minister justin trudeau's commitments
fell short of what they expected we have
a week left
so i'm you know i'm disappointed so far
repeating promises made during the
federal election trudeau committed to
raising the carbon tax reducing oil and
gas emissions by 40 to 45 percent and
phasing out cool fired electricity all
by 2030. he also pledged to stop
shipping thermal cool abroad joined
other countries in a vow to end
deforestation by 2030 and stop new
direct public investment in oil and gas
development by 2022. you know it doesn't
give me any pleasure to say that
canada's
a laggard when it comes to climate
change i mean our you know our emissions
are up uh more than any other g7 country
since paris we have the weakest target
for 2030 in terms of emission reductions
in the g7 canadian environment minister
stephen gebo defended his government's
promises painting them as ambitious
still the former climate activist said
this week he's hopeful for much more the
world is watching
and as sir david attenborough said this
morning
let's work together to turn this
strategy into triumph
for for the people and for the planet
the world is certainly watching mike
relay global news toronto
[Applause]
canada's new defense minister anita
anand has been on the job for less than
two weeks but she's already made a major
change the way criminal cases of
military sexual misconduct will be
handled mercedes stephenson spoke with
the minister for this week's edition of
the west block mercedes
robin military police and prosecutors
will no longer be allowed to investigate
or prosecute allegations related to
criminal sexual offenses like sexual
assault instead they will be transferred
to civilian police and civilian courts
while that may be the case going forward
some survivors are wondering what it
means for cases the military has already
closed the book on will they also be
turned over to be re-examined by
civilian authorities in an interview
with the west block the defense minister
says it's something to consider indeed
there are going to be a number of
questions such as the ones you raised
just now
that we will have to take a look at in
order to ensure that justice is served
and that is my overall goal here that we
have to make sure that the victims of
sexual assault are able to access the
most efficacious justice system possible
where their rights are going to be
protected where the procedural
safeguards are going to be in place and
where we can be assured that they will
have a fair hearing there is still a
laundry list of questions like when case
transfers will begin and what will
happen to non-criminal cases of alleged
sexual misconduct in the canadian armed
forces but for now the new minister says
this is an important start i have
identified this very important reform
which is incredibly significant
for victims of sexual assault to be able
to have their cases tried outside of the
military justice system
in a system
that is going to be able to offer more
experience
and less conflict of interest frankly
for the betterment not only
of the victims themselves but across the
board in terms of the administration of
justice the minister's announcement is
the first major concrete change the
liberal government has announced to the
way the military does things since the
sexual misconduct scandal broke robin
mercedes stephenson in ottawa
and you can watch mercedes full
interview with canada's new defense
minister tomorrow on the west block
right here on global
to the pandemic in canada where a number
of people in ontario are about to roll
up their sleeves for a third time
starting today more vulnerable groups
living in the province are now eligible
to book their kova 19 booster shots
brittany rosen looks at who's qualified
it is better to have this shot to
protect others
it's not only for me eager to get her
third dose of the cobia 19 vaccine 82
year old masako saito slotted her
booster shot appointment this morning on
ontario's online booking platform a
number of populations are now eligible
to receive their third shot including
those 70 and over health care workers
indigenous communities people who
receive two doses of the astrazeneca
vaccine and other at-risk groups i'm
confident
that we will see people stepping up to
get those third dose boosters
and as a city i'm confident that we'll
be able to deliver
and help make it as accessible and easy
as possible officials say there will be
forty thousand appointments available
over the next two weeks boosters will be
available through several channels
including five city-run mass
immunization clinics hundreds of
pharmacies and programs to bring shots
directly to seniors toronto public
health says according to its recent data
those that are unvaccinated are four
times more likely to be infected with
covet 19 five times more likely to
become hospitalized and 42 times more
likely to be admitted to the icu
compared to those that are fully
vaccinated
earlier this week ontario's premier said
he would not mandate vaccines in health
care settings adding booster shots would
be available for workers to add an extra
layer of protection if it means that me
getting an additional booster shot will
increase my ability to not transfer the
virus and make patients and families
safer i'm going to do it i think that is
in the best interest of the the patients
that i might serve
doctors say while the third shop will
play a part in lowering transmission in
communities they underline the role of
kids being immunized we actually will
see a benefit from several different
approaches approach one is expanding the
eligibility of vaccinations to the 5 to
11 year olds crowd by just vaccinating
more people in the community including
the 5 to 11 year old crowd we just will
further reduce transmission in the
community settings canadians continue to
wait anxiously for health canada to
approve the pfizer vaccine for kids in
that age group
brittany rosen global news toronto
a huge music festival in houston texas
has ended in tragedy at least eight
people were killed and dozens of others
injured when fans attending the event
rushed toward the stage while rapper
travis scott was performing the popular
musician quickly tried to stop the
concert but it was already too late
jennifer johnson reports
fifty thousand people crowded rapper
travis scott sold out astro world
festival but the weekend celebration
quickly turned into a nightmare it
happened just after nine o'clock while
scott was performing the crowd began to
to compress towards the front of of the
stage and that caused some panic
and it started causing some injuries
people began to fall out become
unconscious and it created additional
additional panic scott immediately
stopped at one point yelling security
somebody help real quick i don't know
where i guess like a group of people
somebody just pushed and then everything
just like you just it was compressed
medical teams at the festival were
quickly overwhelmed it was like the
biggest mosh pit ever everybody was
pushing and people were jumping
barricades trying to get out scott has
tweeted he is absolutely devastated by
what took place while offering prayers
for those impacted i'm not aware of any
incident of this kind that is taking
place at any one of our special events
pretty much in the last i would imagine
the last 40 40 years
there had been chaos earlier in the day
as crowds rushed and broke through gates
to get into the festival but no one
knows at this point why fans pressed
toward the stage later that night this
is now criminal investigation
that's going to involve our homicide
division as well as narcotics
and we're going to get down to the
bottom of it
scott is one of music's biggest young
stars with eight grammy nominations the
29 year old houston native founded this
festival in 2018 and brought out drake
friday night for a surprise performance
the canadian hip-hop star shared photos
from his set shortly before the tragedy
unfolded now the two-day festival is
shut down as the investigation begins no
parent no friend no sibling should see
their loved one off to a concert by a
world-renowned artist and
not be able to expect them to come home
safely authorities have set up a family
reunification center at a houston hotel
while offering support for those
families whose loved ones will never
come home
jennifer johnson global news washington
at least 98 people are dead and over a
hundred others injured after a fuel
tanker exploded in sierra leone's
capital
the tanker collided with another truck
as it was pulling into a gas station the
drivers tried to warn people to stay
away but in this impoverished country
crowds rushed in to scoop up the leaking
fuel and that's when the gas ignited
a united nations investigator says
myanmar's military rulers have carried
out systemic attacks on civilians that
amount to crimes against humanity
preliminary evidence shows thousands of
civilians have been killed and thousands
more have been arbitrarily detained
since the military coup in february the
independent investigation also found
security forces acted in a coordinated
manner to target specific people
including medical professionals and
journalists
efforts are underway to rescue the
missionaries and their families
kidnapped in haiti a canadian is among
the members of the us-based christian
aid ministries they are abducted last
month after visiting an orphanage
haitian authorities believe they were
taken by the 400 mawoso one of the most
feared gangs in the country the u.s is
spearheading rescue efforts and has
reportedly seen proof that some of the
missionaries are alive
coming up there are lots of help wanted
signs but why are potential employees
ghosting the interview process
businesses across the country are
finding themselves in a tricky position
their doors are open and there's money
to be made but the bosses are facing an
uphill battle trying to find the staff
to operate at full capacity a recent
business development bank of canada
survey found 55 percent of entrepreneurs
reported they're struggling to find
workers and some jobs are going unfilled
for months as ann gaviola explains
there's a trend on the rise that's even
more frustrating
it's being called a workers economy
created by an abundance of help wanted
and not enough help that's leading to an
alarming increase in prospective
employees ghosting it's pretty
frustrating we could get say 10
interviews
confirmed via either email phone
and then two show up
jordan roloda says his restaurant
struggled to compete with government
supports over the summer the shortage
has forced his establishments to cut
back on hours at a time when revenue is
desperately needed after more than a
year of rolling restrictions
when they don't show up it is
it's quite hurtful
not only is ghosting unprofessional it's
uncalled for according to the ceo of a
handful of restaurants bars and pubs in
the guelph area pre-pandemic he says 10
percent of candidates would pull a
no-show these days it's one in three
even worse is when we get through the
process of actually hiring somebody and
there's times where people are just not
shown up for
for the position
according to deloitte canada more than
30 percent of canadian businesses are
reporting labor shortages from the
service industry to white-collar jobs
recruitment experts say this phenomenon
is more common now especially for
low-wage positions and spans many
sectors competing for workers we'll
often call a candidate in the morning
just to make sure they're ready there's
been no change
with covid things pop up out of nowhere
so we try and save frequent contact to
prevent it
recruiters attribute this behavior to
many employment options available to
workers
it's almost like they've shown their
cards in advance and i appreciate that
i'm not wasting my time investing in
them despite time loss checking
references or training a candidate
ghosting does seem to help weed out the
bad apples which is also valuable in
this tight labor market
ann gaviola global news toronto
aviation giant boeing is settling
another lawsuit over at 737 max jets
shareholders sued the company for
failing to address safety concerns
boeing's board of directors has now
agreed to pay more than 237 million
dollars and appoint a new member with
aviation safety experience in 2018 and
2019 two separate 737 max crashes killed
346 people this year boeing agreed to a
2.5 billion dollar settlement with the
u.s to avoid criminal prosecution for
misleading regulators about the jets
safety
up next a hundred kilometers and zero
doubts in honor of those who paid the
ultimate sacrifice
tomorrow runners will return to the
streets of new york for the city's 50th
marathon that's a 42.2 kilometer race
and on the same day a bc man will run
more than double that distance a hundred
kilometers in 15 hours as rumina day
explains he's using his feet to fight
for a cause that's close to his heart
d-day fast approaching
sachin latte on the brink of embarking
on his greatest challenge
i've hated it most of my life actually
running even 5k a struggle for lati when
he started training a year ago the cbsa
officer now ready for a hundred
kilometers more than two marathons in
under 15 hours 100 kilometers is
honestly nothing it pales in comparison
to the sacrifices they've made
[Music]
the run to remember november 7th will
hit all the land border crossings from
chilliwack to yvr
lati raising money for the royal
canadian legion bc yukon command the
gofundme goal 10 000
for veterans mental health i feel 100
connected to the mental health issue
absolutely
connected because lati has been in the
trenches this year i was officially
diagnosed with uh severe anxiety and
depression
i kind of understand how how some people
might feel especially if they've had
some significant traumas when i heard
what what satchen was doing
it just blew me away chair of the bc
yukon command legion foundation says the
money will help provide crucial
equipment counseling and service dogs
for veterans suffering with ptsd with
somebody like sachin putin
putting his money where his mouth is and
his feet and whatnot it's it's amazing
it is amazing we can't thank him enough
and and i encourage everybody to support
sachin let's all get behind him it's
it's a fantastic thing
amazing man
latte motivated by a rich family history
of service dating back to his great
grandfather who served in world war one
under the british indian army the proud
dad says he feels obligated to use his
body to fight for veterans who are
struggling to survive they give me
inspiration
and they give me strength and i'll most
definitely be thinking about them on my
run for sure romina daya global news
vancouver
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is lake george nova scotia
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
and remember if you live in an area that
has daylight saving time tonight's the
night to set back your clocks
[Music]